[Music]
hey what is up guys i'm kbhd here all
right quick breakdown on the timeline of
red cameras every year or so they come
out with an upgrade and they seem to
swap back and forth between a new body
and then a new sensor inside so new body
new sensor inside new body new sensor so
the latest from the bleeding edge of
high-end cine cameras is red's new
helium sensor you may have heard about
it i may have teased it in a previous
video but this is a super 35 8k sensor
so right off the bat it's super overkill
for youtube but i've been shooting red
for a while and this stuff gets me
excited so the helium sensor will come
in two different red bodies in the
weapon which i've showed you did a whole
video on it check it out and the epic w
the epic w is a brand new addition to
red's lineup so yes this is the first
time you're seeing it anywhere this is
your exclusive first look and for those
who have seen my weapon video it'll look
very familiar it sits pretty comfortably
between the lower end raven and scarlet
w and the highest end weapon but still
has most of the benefits of a helium
weapon just at a bit of a lower price so
you still get the modular system that's
such a big part of the red experience
you still get compatibility with every
single one of the accessories that works
with the weapon and any other red and
you're getting the exact same helium
sensor that's in any other helium camera
so the 8k resolution the awesome dynamic
range the red code raw and red's
incredible color science but in a
different body and like i said in the
weapon video the cameras at this level
are like computers attached to sensors
at this point so the different body of
the epic w actually has
different internals different processing
power it's a different computer and so
that's where it's different from the
weapon so this epic w maxes out at 30
frames per second at 8k while the weapon
will go up to 75 frames per second and
it's not quite able to shoot at the
lowest compression ratios the way that
weapon can and the body the body is
actually made of this aluminum alloy so
it's all metal all around as you can see
where the weapon is made of carbon fiber
so the weight is actually different
that's a big draw for a lot of people
and if you're wondering what footage
from the new helium sensor will look
like well to start off you're looking at
it i'm actually shooting this video on a
freshly upgraded helium weapon so the
maxed out carbon fiber beast i've showed
you guys in previous videos is now
rocking the new 8k sensor and so far it
is awesome now if you're wondering why
you can't tell the difference right away
from previous videos it's because number
one this is youtube every clip from
these cameras looks 10 times better on
your computer before it's uploaded and
compressed for streaming on the internet
that's true with any camera and number
two this is published in 4k not 8k
what's funny is the sensor and these
cameras are so new that most video
editing programs don't even support 8k
edits and exports final cut pro is not
really fully ready for it yet adobe has
a beta of premiere just to handle the
footage from this camera and youtube
itself doesn't even let you publish 8k
for the most part 4k is the maximum
resolution for an h.264 video file so
the footage you're seeing was shot in 6k
turns out final cut pro can handle that
and all edited and exported into a 4k
video file so you're watching the 4k
final result if that i mean most people
don't watch in 4k anyway so you can only
kind of get the full benefits on your
end to this point but in theory there
are a couple more benefits to helium
that i'll notice as i shooting with it
more the biggest one besides just
resolution is the much better
performance in low light and that's
always been the thing about these red
cameras is they're really not made for
low light i mean they'll perform well as
far as cinema and tv standards but if
you're looking to constantly be shooting
in really dark environments then you can
do better helium is supposed to
dramatically improve that which you
wouldn't think with the pixels actually
being so much smaller but hey the video
you're watching now is not super well
lit but it's mostly kind of spotlights
in a storefront and it turned out pretty
good and i'm already comfortable with
much higher iso footage like 2000 and
4000 and higher where i wasn't with
older red so that's a good sign and
there's also likely the updated color
science still the incredible dynamic
range so yeah i'm psyched to get out and
start shooting the world and the tech in
it on helium in 8k i probably won't
publish in 8k for a long while i mean no
one has an 8k display right now let
alone a 4k display but we can shoot 8k
now
for the same reason that people shot 4k
a couple years ago to publish in 1080p
for the extra sharpness for the ability
to crop and zoom without losing detail
for more data points for stuff like
motion tracking graphics stabilization
things like that geeky stuff you don't
have to worry about that for the most
part only thing you have to worry about
is that these new sensors will continue
helping in the quest to shoot the most
realistic looking videos possible to
help you choose what tech to buy and i
think we can all appreciate that thanks
for watching i'll talk to you guys the
next one peace
[Music]